Jimmy Kimmel hosts the 68th Emmys...
...and took no time to joke about the US Presidential Elections.
Are you nominated?
I am, yeah!
Wow.
What's that like?
And then about the lack of diversity for the Emmys.
Especially if you're a nominee, please find a white person right now, go ahead.
It shouldn't be hard.
I see a bunch of them right here.
Just take a moment to reach out and say, "Thanks for your bravery."
This made the win for Master of None,...
...a show that centers around an Indian-American actor, for Best Comedy Series Writing...
...so much more meaningful.
Asian parents out there, if you could just do me a favor,...
...just a couple of you, get your kids cameras instead of violins,...
...we'll be all good.
So, let's do it!
Game of Thrones and Veep took home the big awards...
...for Best Drama and Best Comedy Series.
Game of Thrones broke the record for the total wins for any scripted series.
One of the biggest surprises of the evening, Rami Malek from Mr. Robot...
...beat out Kevin Spacey and Liev Schreiber for Best Actor.
Please tell me you're seeing this too.
It was also Tatiana Maslany's first-time win for Best Actress...
...in her role in Orphan Black.
I feel so lucky to be on a show that puts women at the center.
And thank you so much to the Academy.
Thank you.